[Music]
hey Luke here at the altar boys YouTube
channel today we're doing another axe
restoration video now this one has got
me pretty excited it is a really cool
axe head that I'm excited to show you
here just a little bit but what we're
gonna do is we're gonna restore this
thing without using any power tools and
I'm gonna try to use techniques that I
haven't demonstrated before in the past
we different here we've got bearded axes
hewing axes I've got a flaw ski I've
even got some drift railroad hammers
I've got an old-timey sledge pickaxes
lot stuff even this old weird thing but
the one we're gonna do today is right
there this is a hand forged
double-bedded axe from Eastern Europe
somewhere it doesn't have any maker's
marks that I've seen you can see it's a
little bit asymmetrical this side is
bigger than this side and the eye is not
perfectly round and the hole at the top
is a different shape than the hole at
the bottom which is not uncommon with
these old axes well if you like these
restoration videos leave a comment below
telling me which tool you want me to
restore next and in the past I've used
vinegar to get rid of Rasta these angle
grinders I've used things like a vapor
rust and naval jelly and a lot of
different products out there but today
we're gonna use fire and I've got my
Forge here but because this is a no
power tools video I'm not gonna use the
blower I'm just gonna start a basic camp
fire here in the Forge and I'm gonna use
it to bake the rust off this axe and we
gotta get this thing started
you ready now I've had people claim that
this is a power tool it's not just
basically a barbecue lighter attached to
map gas
let's get this fire going using fire to
clean the rust off of steel can be very
effective but there's one big drawback
certain types of steel can be damaged or
changed by doing that low carbon Steel's
like the Steel's used in rebar and the
steel used in some older cheaper axes
isn't affected by throwing them in a
campfire you can heat them and cool them
however and it doesn't really change
their characteristics higher quality
Steel's like what's used in most modern
knives in most modern axes that does get
changed and affected by extreme heating
and cooling and my suspicion is that the
body of the axe is made out of
low-carbon steel and that there's a
sliver of high carbon steel right here
at the edge that's a very common thing
with handmade axes but to know for sure
I'm gonna take a file to it and see what
happens so I've got a piece of rebar
here which is low carbon steel and I'm
gonna rub it with the file to get a feel
for how the file reacts to low-carbon
steel which is softer than higher
quality high carbon steel pay attention
to how much steel gets taken off with
each stroke and you'll feel the file
bite into the steel and take little
pieces off now I'm gonna do the same
thing to the main part of the axe
it feels really similar it's taking off
quite a bit of material it bites in
really good so I think this is low
carbon steel now I'm gonna do the same
thing to the edge now it is taking off
material and I can feel it biting a
little bit but it's noticeably less so I
think this is some sort of tempered
steel heat-treated steel so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go ahead and
clean off this axe in the fire and get
all the rust off but then I'm gonna go
ahead and reheat treat the edge of the
blade
well the axe is starting to change
colors in the fire but Tommy just got
home from school and he has something
way cooler to show us oh my goodness
look how look at that teeth it's
starting to come out don't pull that out
I think just hang in there
yeah I got fliers all right I'm gonna
need some oil so this right here is what
cold peanut oil looks like it's all
coagulated as soon as the ax cools down
it'll get covered in this bright red
rust if you don't coat it in oil while
it's still hot I've got cold peanut oil
here and that works just fine but you
can use motor oil vegetable oil any type
of oil
[Music]
the peanut oil burns off and leaves a
residue that gives it this nice shiny
black color that will protect it for
moisture and from rust it's kind of like
seasoning cast iron you got a nice bed
of coals here we're gonna try to heat
just the edge up when I said using fire
to remove rust was easy I may have
overstated my point a little bit Oh
[Applause]
all right well there we go all the rest
is gone but the axe still has its
character it still looks old and
weather-beaten but now it's covered in a
nice protective layer of oil and it
shouldn't rust up on me as long as they
take care of it well it's another day
and it's time to work on this handle I
have this lovely piece of morado here
it's a South American hardwood
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there we go it's looking pretty good so
far
look at that that looks pretty cool well
it's another beautiful day and it's time
to do some sanding I'm gonna start with
some 60 grit sandpaper I'm gonna just
going to be getting all the marks out of
the wood and once that's all gone then
we're gonna take it from sixty grit on
up all the way up to probably 1,000 or
2,000 grit sandpaper
well the first round of sanity wasn't
that bad it only took me about an hour
45 minutes to get all the RAF's marks
out we're gonna move on to the finer
grit well it took me about three hours
so not too bad but this handle is
looking good now to go sharpen the axe
so what I've got to do is that man come
in and file off all the peaks and make
the blade nice and even then I've got to
put a new bevel on it it's gonna be
really time-consuming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this looks amazing I'm so pleased with
this I need to get a sheath for this
thing it's uh it's pretty sharp all
right look at this thing that wood is
absolutely beautiful look at that
the sheath turned out pretty well too it
was nice and simple I prefer using
rivets but you know stitching works okay
too but uh there we go all right guys we
have a special guest here on our video
this is Vic the Viking he's the Norse
cousin of coot from demolition ranch so
little fun fact there but he is going to
help us test out our ax but before I go
and give him the business end of this
thing we are gonna let Nate and Tom have
a little fun because it's Nate's
birthday happy birthday Nate oh oh he's
a sturdy man
oh he's still good oh yes he's got some
compound fractures this is that first
hit that broke him in two I went about
2/3 the way through a two-by-four and
I'm pretty wobbly set up 2x4 to here is
here is that first hit on the arm that's
that's all that's left of Vic's manhood
right there well guys we hope you
enjoyed watching this video as much as
we enjoyed filming it if you like what
you see don't forget to check out our
cool restoration playlist where we have
all of our ax restoration and tool
restoration videos and check out our
foraging playlist as well if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]